this is the Washington the world has
come to know that's enough but right now
this is also Washington in the middle of
baseball's biggest prize the World
Series it's a really big deal really big
it's brought to a city together joining
forces to push American baseball's
youngest team the Nationals to victory
[Applause]
[Music]
it's been a long time since a baseball
team has given Washington this much to
celebrate the old senators team last
competed in the World Series in 1933
when the country was in the grips of the
Great Depression but even during
post-war prosperity and the senators
were lousy fans still turned up now with
impeachment looming and the airwaves
loaded with accusations of political
witch hunts and fake news I think
anytime you get a DC sports team doing
well it really elevates the city and we
can always use a little bit of unity in
this place I think it's brought people
closer together you know and now that
they're winning they can hurrah for
something in common
hot bats and the joys of singing the
team anthem baby shark are giving
exhausted Washingtonians a reason to
smile now this is a story about
celebrating Washington's unity but my
producer reminds me that we need to
remain bipartisan isn't that right Chris
Rosalind Jordan al-jazeera Washington